en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología soy valentina torre
sánchez y es un gusto acompañarlos
esta vez desde casa a causa del cobi 19
y justamente iniciamos hablando de la
pandemia y de robots porque la necesidad
de restringir los contactos humano
humano ha sido una clara oportunidad
para el desarrollo de la robótica así
que este espacio está dedicado a
mostrarles algunos de estos aparatos que
han sido clave en las últimas semanas
empezamos en múnich en alemania con
france y una robot que limpia y habla y
canta en alemán en un hospital de la
ciudad
delicadamente franz y pide el favor a
las personas que se aparten de su camino
para limpiar hace un segundo llamado más
vehemente y si por tercera vez debe
decirlo derrama lágrimas digitales
limpia tres veces al día y conversa con
los pacientes del lugar además si se lo
piden es capaz de cantar un rap o un
clásico alemán estamos atravesando una
pandemia de coronavirus tenemos que
desinfectar tanto como sea posible
francia puede encargarse de algunos de
los pisos y eso nos da más tiempo para
desinfectar otras superficies
ayrón affection nos trae mucha variedad
de alegría empleados y pacientes están
encantados con su originalidad cuando
hablamos con franz y nos relaja un poco
en nuestro día a día
tuvimos recientemente una paciente que
bajaba tres veces cada día para ver la
disfrutaba muchísimo y decía que se
habían vuelto muy amigas
y es que además de los robots que sirven
para limpiar o para transportar objetos
o pedidos de comida los llamados robots
mascotas se han convertido en una
la clave para algunas personas durante
el aislamiento por ello continuamos en
japón en ese país se ha desarrollado una
nueva generación de androides que
justamente ofrecen su presencia y una
buena charla uno de ellos es charly
fabricado por yamaha mide lo mismo que
un pequeño tazón y de acuerdo con sus
desarrolladores su nariz roja y corbatín
que alumbra le dan un toque de
familiaridad este es mi primer año de
trabajo después de la universidad pero
he estado en casa casi todo el tiempo no
he tenido oportunidad de hablar con
colegas o encontrarme con mis amigos él
está ahí como alguien con quien
conversar que no sea la familia o amigos
mediante redes sociales
un caso similar es el del lobo un robot
del tamaño de un niño pequeño con
grandes ojos redondos y alas de pingüino
que se mueven hacia arriba y hacia abajo
tiene más de 50 sensores y un sistema de
calefacción interno lo que lo hace
cálido al tacto al que reacciona con
sonidos de alegría es fabricado por la
compañía group ex que aseguró que las
ventas mensuales se dispararon luego de
que la pandemia golpear el país
mucha gente se siente sola ya no pueden
encontrarse con gente tanto como
acostumbraban hemos recibido muchísimos
comentarios de nuestros clientes que
dicen que vivir con un robot reduce el
impacto de la soledad y trae una
atmósfera animada a las familias otro de
los campos clave para estos aparatos es
la recolección y entrega de información
a personas en lugares públicos por
ejemplo en los aeropuertos en el
internacional de nairobi la capital de
kenia hay tres robots que llegaron de
china se llaman yasir y en swahili
significa valiente hija qué quiere decir
héroe y tumaini esperanza se encargan de
rociar desinfectante mientras realizan
sus rondas también toman fotos con una
cámara infrarroja que escanea la
temperatura de cientos de pasajeros por
minuto y las registra en una base de
datos además les dicen a quienes no usan
máscara que se la pongan y a quienes
están demasiado cerca que respeten el
distanciamiento social y si su presencia
cada vez aumenta más en los aeropuertos
los hoteles no se quedan atrás el
autobús que hay de sudáfrica fue el
primero del continente en usar
what's recepcionistas ágil xxi my car
llevan los pedidos a las habitaciones
entregan información a los huéspedes y
pueden cargar hasta 300 kilos de
equipaje los responsables del lugar
aseguran que en caso de que lleguen
personas con sospechas de kobe 19 es
este trío el que se encargará de
atenderlas justamente por ser pionero el
establecimiento ha recibido críticas en
un país donde según los datos oficiales
el desempleo ronda el 31 por ciento
y sus robots nunca reemplazarán a las
personas nunca especialmente en un
ambiente de hospitalidad en el que
estamos nosotros los humanos queremos
contacto con la gente interacción social
y los robots no pueden darnos eso pero
lo que sí pueden hacer es ofrecer una
gran experiencia de conserjería wright
consider experience y cada vez más la
robótica es un campo más accesible a
diversos grupos de personas y se ha
convertido en una materia mucho más
común en instituciones educativas en
abuya la capital de nigeria un grupo de
estudiantes creó un aparato
esperan pronto puede llegar a los
hospitales para tratar de forma remota a
pacientes con kobe se llama my robot y
toma la temperatura transportan
medicamentos y permite que las personas
se comuniquen a distancia mediante una
cámara web y una pantalla
grados
y tratamos de encontrar una solución a
ese problema en particular porque sin
los trabajadores de la salud quién
atendería a los pacientes con joven 19
entonces nació my robot porque
buscábamos una manera de reducir el
contacto físico entre los trabajadores
sanitarios y pacientes infectados con
kobe 19
así finalizamos este espacio pero
recuerden que pueden ampliar toda la
información y repetir este y otros
programas en nuestra web france24
puntocom
[Música]